البدايه من تقرير لصحيفه الول ستريت
جورنال يقول ان الحرب في قطاع غزه خلف
الدمار مماثلا في حجمه لاشد حروب المدن
تدميرا في التاريخ الحديث ويشبه الدمار ما
خلفه قصف الحلفاء للمدن الالمانيه خلال
الحرب العالميه الثانيه ويقول روبرت بيب
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه شيكاجو
ومؤلف كتاب تاريخ القصف الجوي ان كلمه غزه
سوف تسجل في التاريخ مع مدينه يسدن وغيرها
من المدن الشهيره التي تعرضت للقصف المدمر
اشارت الكاتبه ب ترو في تقريرها بصحيفه
الاندبندنت الى تحذير جماعات حقوق الانسان
من ان القصف الاسرائيلي على قطاع غزه تسبب
في عدد قياسي من الضحايا بين الاطفال
وتيره قتل لم يسبق لها مثيل منذ جيل كامل
ويقول جيمس دين سلو من منظمه انق الاطفال
ان اكثر من 30 الف طفل قتلوا او شوهوا
خلال الاسابيع الاثن عش الماضيه واضاف هذا
اعلى بمقدار 21 مره من عدد الاطفال الذين
قتلوا او شوهوا في اوكرانيا العام الماضي
نقلت مجله نيوزويك عن القائد السابق لحلف
شمال الاطلسي جيمس ستابس القول ان هناك
فرصه كبيره بشكل غير مريح لتطور الصراع
الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني مستمر الى صراع
اقليمي اوسع نطاقا مضيفا اذا هاجمت
اسرائيل حزب الله فان ايران ستتدخل بشكل
سارخ ما قد يؤدي الى توريط الولايات
المتحده راى الكاتب يوسي فيرتر في مقاله
بصحيفه اريتس ان الاسرائيليين باتوا
متحدين فيما وصفه بكراهيه التحالف الحاكم
الخبيث بقياده بنيامين نتنياهو بعد مرور
عام على تشكيله ويع الاسرائيليون عن
رغبتهم في رحيل نتنياهو عن السلطه ويضيف
الكاتب بدا التحقيق الرسمي في قضايا فساد
نتنياهو قبل سبع سنوات في مثل هذا الشهر
ولم يكن هو ضحيه تاخير العداله بل
الشعب نشرت صحيفه تشاينا ديلي الصينيه
مقالا قالت فيه ان سمعه الولايات المتحده
تعرضت لانتكاسات قويه حيث شهد العالم
برمته نفاقها بشان الصراع الاسرائيلي
الفلسطيني حتى ان دبلوماسيين امريكيين
حذروا الرئيس جو بايدن من ان امريكا تفقد
تاييد العرب لجيل كامل بسبب دعمها الاعمى
لاسرائيل الذي تسبب في ازمه انسانيه مروعه
في غزه في الجارديان تحليل يشير الى ان
روسيا واسرائيل سعتا الى تحقيق توازن دقيق
على مدى عقدين من الزمن في عهد الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين لكن العلاقات بينهما وصلت
الى ادنى مستوياتها اذ ادى موقف موسكو
المؤيد للفلسطينيين الى تاجيج التوترات
ويقول نيكولاي كزانوفا
بق ان روسيا شعرت بان الاحداث في غزه تدفع
دول الجنوب بعيدا عن الغرب وهو ما يصب في
مصلحه موسكو ويرى الكسندر جبوي من مركز
كارينجي ان موسكو ساندت حركه حماس لانه
كان الخيار الاكثر فائده لجهودها الحربيه
في اوكر
ania